[Music]  when it's Paltrow is looking hotter than  ever the 45 year old rocked this itty  bitty bright orange bikini while on  board a yachts with her fiancé Brad  Falchuk in Italy and we've got to admit  love looks good on her the actress and  her man are currently basking in the  Mediterranean Sun with her close friends  Valentino co-founder Giancarlo Giammetti  the GUP founder shared this shot of Brad  and Giancarlo in Capri with the caption  two of my best guys and a famous rock in  January Gweneth opened up to ET about  her main squeeze you talked in goop  magazine and we're so honest about  finding the right man how did you get  over that fear of intimacy I just am  trying to move towards intimacy instead  of being scared of it and I'm really  lucky that I found a partner that's  patient and loves me and is willing to  you know help me with my process I like  how you smile when you talk about her  you get this real twinkle in your eyes  [Applause]